hello and welcome to sampling our bet
don't remember playing him ever but
obviously I have played them perform ok
even have lost one game yeah this is not
particularly challenging got a got a
couple of good options there I'll just
take the center yeah I don't want to
face shut to g5
I think they normally play well not like
this what is 3d three is a strange move
even tempted to play age five yeah come
on that is very strange chess set how
you play it I don't know
I don't know really now he puts the
night on to deform yeah I wake up I got
the square now let's see how he ever
going tries to activate his position
there it's got some odd pieces okay now
if I get the Queen on to the edge valve
I'm just going to made him more or less
it's not going to be well like a man
never been known for my subtle ideas so
maybe maybe just play play in that very
very simple way okay I don't get Darrent
never get into the area just just slow
him and maybe not g4 was a little bit
too simplistic it's definitely
definitely possible
he's got Queen B 5 and IG for was a
total of was there was a city decision
really know that you look at the same
feels a bit silly
three-three is very mysterious
what
it's just what's the idea before I take
care want to terminally we can see four
on top of everything on what's the deal
that's just utterly strange okay anyway
Queen age six stead winning already or
that was the whole idea it's not quite
winning okay
I mean main danger here is to lose on
time anyway
that in the freaking time
it's a kind of game where you afterwards
find that you could have one like intent
on ten different ways and everything
okay I don't know where we are on earth
did I spend all that time
don't really know
yes he has some kind of window as well
that's one of the most annoying losses I
can remember and wife was playing
absolutely terrible I was just totally
atrocious with f4 and everything and
yeah whatever
and I don't know let the clock run down
and allow him to get him get him
allow him a good position somehow
I can take on b5 him I said intermedia
check doesn't doesn't see it okay I
probably wins in some other way as well
[Music]
Queen h4 is a draw I don't want it wrong
the way the game went I want to win
somehow it's not very justified honestly
but
now I'm just blundering the friggin rook
what what was bizarre
there was a completely bizarre game
whatever what am i doing now how many
other narratives right and it was so
bizarre the whole way I mean like some
somewhere here I just have a completely
winning position yeah because what why
did was out of this world bad yeah I
mean like moves like f5 and so on that
this is just well I mean the position is
already terrible because I get h4 in and
he has just dead piece dead piece and
everything is just terrible but I
managed to completely screw that up so
here I'm just winning right - three yeah
that's not a surprise
but I'm I didn't play I played so badly
this Knight g4 was already bad I should
just play farm one yeah get towards the
center probably it's it's it's already
oh it's still very good for a long time
I'm fairly certain but Queen h6 is over
already why I have g5 and then I can
just take in three okay g5
g5 is a absolute killer I'm that's an
absolute killer now even this for this
g5 Knightley he just gets completely
smashed on the King and I've been I
managed to bungle that up quite badly
before I don't know before anyway so
Bishop d7 and somewhere here I'm
bungling it up so there are still many
moves that win D takes e4 Bishop a4 and
this is princess not winning him now now
I don't have anything good and here I
should I should just lose so I'm again
winning
we have many I mean he's I'm still
having an attack but by now I had ten
seconds not ten seconds and then you
just have to do whatever Bishop have six
there and this is this will just totally
losers
once this Bishop takes Knight eggs yeah
you can just take b5 and and and it's
over okay applied this one that's also
like plus a million and here quick Queen
takes h3 just Bishop a queen should be
five and over I mean just just just the
Queen as I'm just using the Queen okay
and now I'm so somehow in the game and
even winning again yeah now okay the
engine just wants to play the ending
yeah just take of course yeah I don't
know I wanted to have sticks and tid I
wanted to originally just give the
perpetual with Queen edged forward then
I decided okay and just I watch one to
try to win the game and then crazy
enough here rupee Edwin's it's not
exactly difficult to spot
and then completely complete craziness I
play rook g8 MOOC d8 and the answers
with rook e8 then this is just like hey
no idea I have no idea how to how to
come and hit what a strange game okay
guys that was a hope at least
entertaining thanks for watching